mais la sécu qu'un petit peu comme ton
grand frère
oui je sais c'est moi en plus j'ai
franchement dect en galère ces mots que
tu appelles c'est vrai était le deuxième
non mais vraiment l'autre répond pas et
comme l'autriche et ne répondent jamais
ça exactement donc souvent tu m'appelles
parce que vous avez compris bien sûr
c'est la soeur de thiamène de mousse
non mais vous savez moi j'ai tous mes
membres diabel voilà alors je peut se
permettre parce que ça un copain mais
oui j - oui voila je vais là je sens le
malaise mais un nombre à jamel qui nous
regardent tous sûrement et on lui fait
des gros bisous mais qu' il aime pas
d'accord pour pouvoir votre gueule alors
bas mêlera médias bas je suis pas sûr du
spectacle je suis plus heureuse comme ça
alors il faut savoir mais leurs abeilles
à celador mais si une chienne elle
vannes tunes koi même mois c'est à dire
qu'elle va tout le monde
elle n'a pas de nom mais elle n'a pas de
limites c'est pas faux mais comme ça
tout le monde est content ne me siècle
et sans pitié d'ailleurs dans ton
spectacle tu te feras casse oui tout à
fait voilà eh bien j'ai un truc pour
l'auto dérision mais je préfère qu'on
dise que en fait je sais pas je j'ai
fait des pubs givenchy pss pour dire que
j'étais grosse avant qu'on me le dise
par exemple ah oui givenchy c'est vrai
j'ai envie d'en de m'embrouiller avec
givenchy balancier aggrave valence
agathe un truc comme ça va peut-être un
échec cuisant mais mêlera on est très
content de t'avoir et plus ce soir peut
dire
je dimanche soir j'étais devant enquête
exclusive genre tu l'as vu mon âge un
peu plus en tant que spectatrice lambda
sait même pas j'en peux plus en tant que
rebut ou quoi ou musulmane jusqu'où
d'aller à l'est et là il a été trop mal
on rappelle le thème c'est l'amour
l'amour ma gueule on était des robots
frère mais ça a pas d'amour chez nous
nos coeurs il bat pas on la connaît ma
croûte mais moi je me suis dit moi je te
jure je crois que c'est une vanne
on s'est vus de l'amour non mais ça a
dépassé ya une vidéo
je crois qu'on a une vidéo j'étais
énervé et j'étais là quand même regarder
bien vu qu'il y avait un gros souci avec
bernard de la villardière et c'est
depuis hier soir tu n'arrêtes pas avec
lui c'est quoi le souci c'est un souci
avec ces reportages où les thèmes de ses
reportages si j'ai bien compris c'est
l'islam
les maghrébins et l'amour et maghrébins
et timèn les maghrébins c'est pas
quelqu'un de bien je n'aime pas voir les
embrouilles jeu tout est orchestré pour
qu'on ait peur et que dans l'isoloir on
on passe de 33 % à 72 il est là bernard
de la vie de la villardière tu lui dis
quoi nique ta mère
bon voilà c'est fait c'est ce qui
s'appelle le grand débat en tout cas
tant c'est vous qui adorez m6 et taverne
oh que oui je vous les connaissez bien
oui comment ça se fait que revanche m6
adhère mais autorise tous ces sujets
tous les tous les dimanches alors à
marcher alors je ne suis pas un patron
de m6 aurait non non c'est tellement pas
de tabernaux quant au coeur dur c'est
vrai que c'est tellement pas m6 mais bon
là il n'y voit pas de mal et puis lui il
peut il le vend comme si voilà il ya au
contraire ils montraient des choses ils
essaient de le vendre comme si voilà au
contraire ils méprisent la lumière sur
certaines sur certains trous absolument
c'est de l'hypocrisie oui nous fait
croire que ce sont des reportages de
société et c'est toujours 13 idéologisé
stigmatisation des musulmans
ostracisation c'est mal ce que vous
faite j'en ai ras le bol je partage
totalement votre indignation alors là il
ya pas mal de gens qui se dit on se sont
dit on à changer de chaîne ou pas non
sur ces vital comme à la télé mais c'est
vrai que c'est incroyable en tout cas
voilà ça n'aurait pas dû dire nique ta
mère
mais c'est mon côté gennevillois qui est
ressorti la ligne 13 j'ai 26 ans je vais
y aller moi je venais pas là je vais
aller par là moi je vais ben on va
arrêter comme arrêter la saignée au fond
ce qu'on va arrêter là bercy mal arabe
et d avertir